TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
IMPEACHMENT IS MANY THINGS,
IT CAN BE THE POLITICAL
DEATH PENALTY.
IT CAN A
CORRECTION.
THE BEST WAY TO CORRECT A
MISTAKE IS TO NOT MAKE IT IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
TO BE INFORMED ON FRONTS END
AND RESEARCH AND ANALYZE AND
INVESTIGATE BEFORE CASTING A
VOTE.
DECISIONS CARRY CONSEQUENCE,
ALL THERE IS OF LIFE,
INCLUDING ELECTIONS.
IMPEACHMENT SHOULD NOT BE A
REMEDY FOR BUYERS REMORSE.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
SO SEVERE, AND DRAMATIC AND
LETHAL, YOU CANNOT WAIT
UNTIL THE NEXT ELECTION
CYCLE.
CALIFORNIA REMOVED SAN
FRANCISCO PROSECUTOR. PROSECUTE.
YES, SOMETIMES VOTER SHOULD
LIVE WITH CONSEQUENCES OF
THEIR POOR DECISIONS.
BUT YOU SHOULD NOT DIE
BECAUSE OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF YOUR POOR ELECTION
CHOICES, THAT IS A PRICE FAR
TOO STEEP, HAVING A POOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS A
THREAT TO YOUR PHYSICAL WELL
BEING AND PERHAPS OUR LIFE,
A THREAT TO LAW, AND ORDER,
A THREAT TO JUSTICE, A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
EVEN IF DEMOCRACY GAVE THAT
YOU INCOMPETENT D.A. IN THE
FIRST PLACE, SOMETIMES A
DEMOCRACY FIRST BE SAVED
FROM ITSELF.
WE CALL THOSE REPUBLICS.
PROSECUTORS HAVE A UNIQUE
ROLE, THEY ENFORCE THE LAW,
THEY MAKE THE DECISIONS
WHICH IMPACT HOW THE REST OF
US VIEW THE LAW AND OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM, PROSECUTORS
WHO CUT CORNERS OR BREAK THE
RULES RUN THE RISK OF
CONVICTS AND INCARCERATING
INNOCENT PEOPLE THAT IS AN
AFRONT TO JUSTICE AND A
THREAT TO FREEDOM, THEY
SHOULD BE REMOVED.
THE CONSEQUENCE OF WAITING
TOTE NEXT ELECTION ARE TOO
SEVERE.
PROSECUTORS WHO REFUSE TO
ENFORCE THE LAW AND VILIFY
COPS AND CODDLE CRIMINALS
ARE ALSO AN AFFRONT TO
JUSTICE, A THREAT TO FREEDOM
AND YOUR LIFE, THEY SHOULD
BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE
IMMEDIATELY WITH DISMATCH,
LARRY KRASNER IS ALLEGEDLY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
PHILADELPHIA, MEDIA LOVES TO
CALL HIS KIND A PROGRESSIVE
PROSECUTOR, HE IS NOT A REAL
PROSECUTOR, REAL PROSECUTORS
DON'T SPEND MORE TIME
TALKING ABOUT JUSTICE FOR
VIOLENT CRIMINALS THAN THE
VICTIMS, THEY DON'T WAIT
UNTIL SOMEONE IS DEAD TO
TAKE A CAS SERIOUSLY.
THEY DON'T REPLACE
EXPERIENCED TRIAL LAWYERS
WITH BRAND-NEW ATTORNEYS WHO
DON'T KNOW WHICH SIDE OF THE
COURTROOM TO SIT OREAL
PROSECUTORS KNOWS RACE OF
THE VICTIMS NOT JUST THE
DEFEND ANDS, SHE NOT A REAL
PROSECUTOR, IS HE
PROGRESSIVE?
I DON'T KNOW.
DO YOU CONSIDER A SKYROCKETS
MURDER RATE PROGRESS?
OR MORE VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
CRIMES PROGRESSER TO
DISMISSING VIOLENT CRIME
CASES TO BE PROGRESS.
AND RELEASES SAME CRIMINALS
OUT OF JAIL TIME AFTER TIME
AFTER TIME TO BE PROGRESS,
THERE IS A JOB FOR THE LARRY
KRASNERS OF THE WORLD, THAT
IS A PUBLIC'S DEFENDER
OFFICE.
BUT NOT DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
YES, THERE ARE TIMES VOTERS
HAVE SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES
OF POOR CHOICES AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
PROSECUTOR WHO REFUSE TO
ENFORCE THE LAW WHO PUT
CRIMINALS AHEAD OF THE
VICTIMS WHO
DISREGARD THE LAW BECAUSE
THEY WISH THE LAY IS
DIFFERENT ARE ANED IN THREAT
TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE, PROSECUTOR MAKE LIFE
AND DEATH DECISIONS.
WHEN IT COMES TO LIFE AND
DEATH, YOU ONLY GET ONE OF
EACH.
IF YOU HAVE A PROSECUTOR WHO
DOESN'T KNOW WHETHER TO
VALUE YOUR LIFE MORE, OR THE
LIFE OF PERSON
TRYING TO TAKE YOUR LIFE,